in this video we're going to dig a
little bit deeper into the notion of
perfectly competitive market so we're
think about under what scenarios a firm
would make an economic profit or an
economic loss in them now as a reminder
these perfectly competitive markets are
something of a theoretical ideal there's
a few markets in the real world that are
truly perfectly competitive some might
get close but most markets are someplace
in a spectrum between perfectly
competitive and at the other extreme say
something like a monopoly but here we're
talking about perfect competition and
perfect competition the firm's products
aren't differentiated there's no
barriers to entry or exit and so in that
situation the market supply and demand
curves are going to define the price in
the market which are also reading to
find the marginal revenue for these
firms they're all going to be price
takers they're gonna be passive in terms
of price whatever the market price is
that's the price that they are going to
sell their products for and their
decision is really what quantity does to
produce and sell and whether to enter or
exit the market so let's look at that a
little bit so these are just your
classic and supply demand curve supply
and demand curves you might see for a
market the first few units in the market
there's a huge marginal benefit so
people are willing to pay a lot but then
each incremental unit the marginal
benefits a little bit lower and lower
and lower and lower and that's what we
have those that downward sloping demand
curve and then on the supply curve the
first unit in the market might be fairly
inexpensive to produce but then the
marginal cost gets higher and higher and
higher and where they meet where the
supply and demand meet that tells us the
equilibrium price in equilibrium
quantity in the market and we can show
that with that line and let's just say
that equilibrium price is $10 and as I
just mentioned that's going to have to
be the price that all of the firm's and
these might not be all of the firm's in
the market but all of the firms in the
market if we're talking about a
perfectly competitive market would just
have to take that price so given that
what what quantity what firms a B and C
produce and which which of these firms
would be profitable or not I encourage
you to pause the video and think about
those two questions if you could just
which of these firms would be profitable
or not and we're talking about economic
profit in this context all right well
let's look at firm a first well firm a
for any of them it is not rational to
produce a quantity where the marginal
cost is higher than the marginal revenue
that the firm's getting and remember
this line right over here this line
right here which is the price line
that's also that is price which is equal
to marginal revenue and so for that
extra unit if you're if you can't sell
it for more than you're producing then
you wouldn't you wouldn't produce an
extra unit so it's rational for them to
produce more and more and more the
marginal cost goes higher and higher
until right at the point that marginal
cost is equal to marginal revenue which
is equal to price the market price which
they're just going to take so it's
rational for this firm to produce this
quantity right over here so I'll just go
to quantity I'll say quantity for that
firm now is this firm I'm going to be
profitable or not
well this quantity what's its average
total cost well its average total cost
is right over there and so for every
unit it's going to make this difference
between the price or the marginal
revenue it's getting and it's average
total cost and so one way to think about
the profit of this firm is and we're
talking with economic profit it's going
to be the area of this rectangle right
over here so let's say if the average
total cost at that quantity is let's say
that this is $8 then this height of the
rectangle is 10 minus 8 the height right
over here let me do this in a different
color this height right over here is $2
and then the width is going to be the
quantity of that firm and so let's say
the quantity of that firm let's say it's
10,000 units a year 10,000 10,000 units
per year and so the area right over here
would be $2 times 10,000 it would be
$20,000 $20,000 per time unit for
time unit if we're talking all of this
to say per year now let's go to firm be
using that same analysis is firm be
making an economic profit or is it not
making an economic profit
well firm B is once again going to be a
price taker and so the price right over
here the equilibrium price in the market
is going to be equal to the price that
that firm has to take which is going to
be its marginal revenue curve and that's
why it's a flat marginal revenue curve
because no matter what quantity they
produce they're gonna get that same
price and it wouldn't be rational for
them to produce a quantity where
marginal cost is higher than marginal
revenue and so they would produce right
over there now what is their economic
profit at this quantity so this is
quantity of the first second firm firm B
all right like that maybe that is firm a
and maybe this is also it looks about
the same I'll make them a little bit
different let's say that's the nine
thousand five hundred units per time
period well here the average total cost
at that quantity is equal to the
marginal cost so which is equal to the
marginal revenue so at that quantity
whatever that ten dollars are getting
per unit they're also spending on
average ten dollars per unit another way
to think about the area of that
rectangle is going to be zero because it
has no height so this this situation
right over here the firm has zero zero
economic all right zero dollars of
economic profit and then last but not
least let's think about firm C pause
this video and think about what its
economic profit would be well like we've
seen it would be rational for it to
produce the quantity where marginal cost
is equal to marginal revenue which is
equal to the market price so it would
produce this quantity right over here
and let's say that that quantity is nine
thousand units and what's its average
total cost then so at nine thousand
units its average total cost let's say
that that is $12 right over there so
what's its economic profit so for every
unit its selling its
ten dollars and it's costing 12 dollars
on average to produce it so it's taking
an economic loss of two dollars per unit
so two dollars per unit so this height
right over here is two dollars times the
units times 9000 you're going to have
two times 9000 you're going to have an
$18,000 not economic profit but economic
economic loss now one thing to think
about is why would any firm be in this
situation well it's important to think
about things in the short run versus the
long run in the short run we've talked
about this analysis right over here
where a firm can decide what quantity it
would produce that is rational it's
fixed costs are fixed in the short-run
we've done that study that in multiple
videos but in the long run it's fixed
costs aren't fixed and so the firm could
decide to enter or exit the market and
so so for our MC while they've already
put in those fixed costs it is actually
rational for them to do it because
they're actually able to make their the
the marginal revenue they get up to that
quantity it's at least they're able to
more than cover their marginal costs and
then they're able to eat up or I guess
you could say take care of some of their
fixed costs but they're still not able
to run an economic profit so in the long
run it wouldn't be rational for this
firm to stay in the market they would
likely exit the market